of this week's episode of GameSpot after
dark we talk about Platinum's a new game
they announced and altered carbon season
- the timestamps are in the description
if you want to skip ahead thank you for
watching hello and welcome to episode 30
of GameSpot after dark my name is Jake
I'm your host this week we are joined by
two more hola how's it going Lucy James
hi
and Simon cardi from the UK / IGN yes
both came into the wrong office
but you wouldn't let me leave yeah
you're stuck inside dude we've talked
about this what we just record what us
three play while we play some clips of
like choice quotes of things but there
was a little while where we were talking
about scene if we could try to get like
a crossover podcast going to remember oh
we talked about that one time and I was
still in the UK we were like what is
like a monthly crossover podcast where
we had like I join UK and GameSpot UK
just come together and just chat for a
bit and we both host it and then that's
it like it's just to like get rid of
that that kind of a kind again bring
down yeah bring down the walls cuz
people think are they hate each other
but actually we very much don't we're
you in the u.s. in the u.s. that people
are like proper West Side Story and but
in there and the UK are so close you
know is that rivalry yeah yeah
constantly walk upon each other's
buildings clicking yeah except I like
almost never walk past there but I just
don't go that far yeah it's nice I
listen every week I enjoy it I do our
choice I'm not even forced good good
anyway this is GameSpot's official video
game podcast but a lot of times
about video games this week we are going
to go into what we've been playing of
course the Chris from Dayton Ohio
segment we're gonna do that with Simon
in a bit and then we have some new
stories we're gonna get into and finally
we're gonna wrap it up with some
listener questions but let's start with
the Chris from Dayton Ohio 2.2 there's a
bit of an update here that I really
enjoyed us yeah so for people who know
this was originally by Chris from Dayton
Ohio but Kevin from West Hartford has
updated their yeah he's given us patch
notes however he was supposed to do a
two point three version however it was
too busy with things I'll read why he
was too busy so we're gonna have to go
with the two point two versions
hopefully we'll get two point three one
of these days but you know he's got some
more important things to deal with right
now
anyway it reads after our crew I regret
to inform you that this week's patch
will not be published this week in time
for your Wednesday recording as the
developer failed the critical listened
to last week's podcast certification
requirement in related news the
developers wife has personally seemed
increasing your future has personally
seen to increasing your future listener
base by one with the birth of one
healthy baby boy who will reach the
prime podcast listener age on schedule
sorry for any conveniences this patch
delay may have caused and as always I am
listening to the podcasts feedback for
future improvements Congrats
[Music]
yeah I'm a little annoyed but you gotta
make two sometimes yeah I mean he'll
listen to this week's yeah I think you
listen yeah yeah do you remember the
Chris from Dayton Ohio 2.2 questions I
don't remember them you bet printed it
out because I'm not gonna remember that
let's go are you ready oh god no but
let's do it alright gone in mmo's DPS
healer tank DPS
in pokemon grass fire or water started
aha gross because he's a snitch
I just went Greek II lost my most recent
sonic mreow mreow life is strange
Walking Dead gone home or what remains
of Edith Finch eat a Finch games that
that's made our game that's made you the
angriest i watch the game because excuse
you Wow sir all right
Mortal Kombat a street fighter Mortal
Kombat wow I'm not a fighting game I
enjoy incredible scenes halo over watch
quake siege or Call of Duty oh I'll
watch of siege
so overwatch is my favorite game of all
time but like the last six months I
choose to play see each overall interest
hell yeah - me too it's tired enemies
today actually I think I said halo for
my nanny most desired smash ultimate
edition character you know play smash
pick any character Mega Man he's in that
I like them let's get makoto him from
persona
let's have to pursue I mean she sort of
it should come she has a common leave
you didn't ask for like I don't know an
overwatch katenka get to chenko in there
I'll get like castle from C channel I
know
linear open-world
open-world an FPS games shotgun SMG
assault rifle or sniper rifle assault
rifle although mmm because you play a
love great yet not revolver oh yeah
pistol revolver counts like a handgun I
guess yeah co-op single-player or
multiplayer single paw Xbox Playstation
Nintendo PC or oh yeah playstation
favorite controller ever oh you know I
like a dual shock for I just like the
feel of it or the NES controller because
I have a soft spot for oh those Peters
right yeah huge yes NES right hmm maybe
I don't know I listen last week but be
sure I forgot
pop-tarts a toaster strudel can I pick
sign British yeah you can't get parts of
the Gregg's just loads of Americans
gonna be googling bake bake bake
well Kevin make sure had steak baked do
this Oh pop-tarts toaster strudels I've
never had a toaster strudel I've never
had one and I picked a toaster strudel I
picked that based on the fact that I
don't like pop-tarts that much is it
just a toasted Apple Street yeah I just
in my in my mind I'm imagining it's like
a McDonald's apple pie
Oh mouth off exactly yeah
is she is it cheating if a friend tells
you how to beat a part you're stuck on
no it's nice it's friendly is it
cheating if you save scum no I do it you
will not I don't care
Daniel Dwyer Dan Reicher
I enjoy noclip play so I'll go okay okay
game on a couch or at a desk
on my bed yeah I think Beth is supposed
to be any other day yeah if that couch
there
if Kevin were desperate yeah if Kevin
went fathering a child who probably
about did that by now you hate to see it
hate to see it favorite gaming sack
Maltesers I think they are here libels a
honeycomb ish yeah it's like honey so
spirit covered yeah yeah so like
whoppers here maybe whoppers are just
something else in the UK yeah like a BK
whopper
yeah we've got that too or they know I
don't know they're called but the same
thing yeah it's disgusting do Americ
write this because this came up today I
saw NBC the IGN Nintendo Park I say like
I'm with a huge frothing about NBC 500
sitting a live show for the 500th
episode and I was like did they not know
I know I know it's the meme from like
the Ikaruga review from years and years
ago but like in the UK you don't say
Frost yeah probably but even if you're
talking about milk or you know you say
I'm froth in milk you don't just say for
think us as different connotations I
don't even know if frothing milk
frothing at the mouth for anything it's
a different kind of it's just it's just
the word with bad mouthfeel so many in
the briefcases yep yeah this is the
longest sections of it yeah
music econia Sakurai Miyamoto Kodaka
or Kojima well just to keep up
traditional I'm gonna say Hoshino
[Laughter]
is it that's it that's the final
question latke that's you in a nutshell
now we know everything about you
yeah in 20 questions yeah is there other
stuff yeah we've got we also have like
mutually assured destruction yeah your
love it's like you know when Batman has
his like his briefcase full of every
Justice League members weakness oh let's
have like blackmail yeah we have back
black McCarthy so if one person goes
down you're all going down oh yeah it's
an arms race sometimes you are meet one
of you it's Lucy yeah no although I I
figured I figured out that and I haven't
done it so you you did post a clip where
cuz I I do this unintentionally but when
we're playing overwatch I just talk [ __ ]
and I was talking about some absolute
nonsense some Twitter account had
followed me it was the kind of funny
porn whoa oh yeah and it was someone and
I was just explaining about this Twitter
girl chord yeah and you got a quad kill
I think his widow maker
I was really I was talking about the one
on junket own but I know that was that
was the other one that was that guy he
kept sending me naked pictures in my ya
know saying like this Twitter company
all of me that bio was combining my two
favorite things kind of funny and born
and I was like
okay telling the guys about it and I
unintentionally ruined cars kind of
funny on in the middle of like no I
didn't I didn't look too deeply
no you better if anyone wants to combine
their favorite two passions and I
streamed over what yesterday with Sam
yeah but no no you were I'd watch it I
wouldn't tell her I wouldn't cancel you
guys someone else might TS L sounds like
you try you see isn't it snowing
actually calls me Simon tonight I know I
caught your card details please please
buy it
[Laughter]
there we go two more what if you can
play in this week so I have been playing
a game for review um it's called a grand
blue Fantasy Versus I can't say it is
indeed it's very much indeed I can't say
too much about it I don't want to say
too much about it the preview embargo
has left two for review embargoes coming
later on down the line soon but I will
say that it's an interesting fighting
game because it's made by Arc System
Works who have done the Dragon Ball
fighters flying game and also persona 4
arena so they're very good at taking
other people's properties and making
them into amazing fighting games and
granblue fantasy is a incredibly popular
mobile game it's like a turn-based RPG
with gotcha mechanics like the crane
game style mechanics in Japan outside of
Japan no one knows so it's it's like an
interesting fighting game in terms of it
has the clout to kind of just muscle in
on a jean rrah
that's usually takes years and years and
years of dedicated like entries to
really make a name for yourself but
fundamentals are really really
interesting it's like unlike a game mark
system works would usually make they
make anime fighters which if you've seen
Dragonball you probably are familiar
with like very moving around quickly in
the air and doing insane stuff this is
like scaled back into like a classic
capcom style fighting game so I've been
playing a bunch of that for review and
the big to be one of the big draws of it
is it's got like a fully fledged RPG
story mode so what score you given Jim
we don't make mistakes like that here
this is their first game since Dragon
Ball Z fighters right I'm gonna say yes
they put out so many games now fighting
games that I've lost track of them but
I'm pretty sure this is the first one
since fires a year but yeah I'm I'm
playing a lot of that right now
I think I've played enough to start
writing my review so I'm probably going
to do that today after we go to the
Cheesecake Factory I get to celebrate
your birthday
let's celebrate my birthday yeah so yeah
that's been a fun game another game I've
been playing is kunai which is kind of
like this side-scrolling it's a
Metroidvania game here that Liverpudlian
kid from dude the kunai can yeah I've
got the K in if you listen real closely
you can hear the K at the end but yeah
that's a it's a Metroidvania game and I
don't know it's it's kind of really easy
to play it doesn't so far it's it's not
like a remarkable in any way like it's
not doing anything really distinct I
mean it has one key hook but in all
other regards is a fairly standard
straightforward Metroidvania I think the
thing that I like about it is it's
really easy to play and it's got like a
sense of inertia and momentum to it the
main mechanic is you have to can I
which you kuna and they're like mapped
to shoulder buttons and you almost use
them as spider-man would so when you
fire them out they kind of create a rope
which he swing from so you're like
you're moving around the environment
quicker than you would in most
Metroidvania games it feels more like
later game Metroid where you've got like
the various like I think it's pop jump
where you like can move around very
easily and like the shoulder - and move
kind of like do the aerial jump off the
shoulder - so it's got that kind of like
inertia and momentum based gameplay and
it's like the characters are like a the
main character is just like a TV screen
with a face on it well like from saga
Jesus yeah yeah saga but kind of like
but it's like got a cape as well but
it's like what I like about it's like
it's very emotive when you're playing
like when you're running across screen
it looks slightly like like suspicious
of what's going on and when you start
attacking an enemy with your like kunai
it's got like kind of like a shovel
knight mechanical you can do like a
shovel drop bounce
attack on them but like when you're
doing it it looks a bit angry and it's
like doing that kind of stuff and when
it's swinging it looks kind of happy and
you can see because it's so big you can
see the face constantly and it's just
like a weird little character moving
around and having fun
and I just got like a futuristic vibe to
it where like the shop is like you can
only use the shop if you're close to a
router in the UK and he says mobile in
it you've just said router localized it
people give me [ __ ] I localized them for
the audience we have quite similar yeah
that's my it's route it's really like
there's a has a connotation for Rooter
that I won't get into in East London
which I don't know and I give her a good
ruin yes yeah I tried I try to stay away
from that as much as possible I feel
like if if ever anyone's gonna be the
person to go there it will be me
the overwatch clips the overwatch them I
mean as in
take a conversation and yeah yeah I mean
yeah so like it is route up I just its
Brutus got a bad mouth feel as well yeah
Evans not back there this last week
Evans misophonia is like off-the-charts
so whenever I so whenever we record like
I'm usually hanging out with him and
children are certain to help him and
like we talked about this in the back
while it was happening
every time we do the can into the Mike
thing it like destroys his wall it's a
great ongoing gag for us and a great
sound for Sonny how weird my mind is
when you say the word root ah I usually
think of routability te Lithuanian gold
medal winner in swimming
only excited to make a video about their
about five years ago say a1 in a way
he's on two we stopped doing that three
just because you haven't heard old
episodes misophonia is the the hatred of
sounds mouth noises mouth noises pizza
was bringing up that it's repetitive
noises - so like and it could be
repetitive sites like a foot tap or yeah
that was one of those I didn't know if
that word was people made it up because
myself alone it sounds like yeah my one
is breathing and it's so mine if I can
hear breathing it's so Andy Cortes over
I kind of funny is playing blood-borne
currently and like I'm his currently his
like blood-borne guide in some like
whenever he has an issue yeah I'm his
game FAQ and I can send me a message and
be like I'm looking for this thing or I
need help with this thing usually he's
he's great a game so he's doing
perfectly fine without me but
occasionally it's easy to get lost in
that game and yesterday it was like I'm
looking for this boss because one of the
bosses the shadow of you on I'm there in
like the forbidden woods and you can get
lost if you get killed and don't open a
shortcut so user I can't find them again
alright I'll record a video and then I
recorded the video of me doing it and
it's just like it's me holding the phone
up to
to just take her video of it and then I
was watching it back and I could hear
myself breathing and it likes a awful
crime I so he's waiting I don't want to
call you about him but I sit next to you
we go to the cinema once a week
both have AMC ælis weeds legal cinema
once a week it's the berry Network your
beard is really loud yes and I have I
have a I have an annoying like a habit
of scratching my beard times and I
always have to remind myself to stop and
if that usually is a sign a good sign
that I'm bored wait I'm trying to think
what film did I go see with you and you
were doing that it was knives out oh
yeah see like did your hair doing what
you call it 17 no I was very stressed
and also there was us but like it's when
I'm bored I just like start twiddling my
thumbs and I start speaking yes so the
thing I've noticed is people with cheap
headsets online you can hear them
breathing more than if they've got nicer
headset and that drives me crazy and I
know and I'm super self like I've got a
pretty nice headset but I'm still like
very self-conscious that other people
can hear me breathing while I'm playing
cuz I hate the sound of it so much well
when we play if I'm really relaxed I
always say I'm going horizontal like
when we play I just slowly because we
playing we played bet that's not so
wrong listen I need to quickly pivot in
tangent I was talking to someone send
them a message and I tried to say I've
got to run and instead I said I've got
to rub I was I'm just gonna delete
myself no no anyway so whenever we're
playing overwatch and I'm lying in bed I
sort of slowly just slide down and I'm
fully horizontal but it means that my
mic is like here yeah and right
underneath where I breathe out of my
nose and I don't realize it until one of
the horizontal yeah
what's the weather forecast
yes please standing in the wind tunnel
yeah anyways switch it is on a switch
here so if you want to kind of buy
upgrades you need to be close to a route
and you got like all that Wi-Fi symbols
and everything like that and it's got
like a futuristic technology has kind of
like been part of the post apocalypse
and weird stuff is happening it's light
on story so far but I don't think I'm
it's one of those games where I don't
think I'm gonna play it all the way
through but right now I'm having a
really good time just jumping in and out
and having like going from point to
point really easy to move about and it's
like got a charm to it it's got like
this almost like classic it reminds me a
lot of Yoshi's Island where you know how
Yoshi's Island has like it's colorful
but it's also like slightly washed out
like it's gone white overlay to it
almost it's got that kind of vibe to it
so I'm having a good time playing that
I'm having a good time yeah and then I
actually Lucy's got this as her thing so
I'll let her talk about that oh wow what
a lovely segue mm-hm so I remember 2017
time and I did a bunch of videos about
altered carbon mmm which I keep pulling
Binary Domain yeah it's just they have
the same thing in my head so we've been
watching season 2 the reviews coming out
early next week it goes up on Netflix
today
it's not as good as season 1 by oh yeah
I could not get through season 1 and I
really like cyberpunk stuff like I read
what did I read last year Neuromancer
which I thought was great and like I was
getting into that and I was like alright
I'm finally gonna give all three carve
another chance I was like I just don't
think this is problem for me was it came
out it felt like a week after like Blade
Runner 2049 yeah I was gonna say there
are yeah I think it did come out the
same time it's like oh they're Blade
Runner and then season 2 I feel like it
would have hit at the same time as oh
close enough to cyberpunks launch day if
they'd one of my main problems with
season 1 was Joel Kinnaman I know you so
I work for him too Anthony Mann yeah I
live for now I can ask because Anthony
Mackie I just feel like he's one he's on
the verge of doing equip and it doesn't
fit that I find him very he'll illness
as an actor guess you never miss huh
sadly anyway so all to carbon set in the
distant future where humanity can
essentially be your your consciousness
can be put on a sort of USB stick that
goes in the back your net called a stack
and bodies are called sleeves and get an
organic sleeve or you can get a
synthetic sleeve and the rich is the
expose a lot of really cool themes so if
you're really rich you can have constant
backups of your stack and if your sleeve
dies then you can just go straight into
a clone body and then you can basically
live forever and the longer you live the
more out of touch you become with your
own humanity whereas on the flip side
the poor are really struggling it's an
awful world for them they have all these
AI and AI is so advanced that AI is more
human than humanity because AI is built
to help whereas humans are becoming
dissociated with everything and there
are some really cool concepts in there
like in season 1 they had this amazing
episode where the main character gets
tortured in VR but because of the
training that he's had the specialist
training he can sort of combat
vr constructs there's always kind of
cool stuff there's really messed up
things that they do with religion like
religion neo see which is if you're a
Catholic you don't believe in being spun
back up put in a new body or anything so
once you die you you die and they play
into that and it's a really cool mystery
in the first season and then there's
this whole other revolutionary sect
called the calloused s-- who believe
that death should be final and that
humanity is losing something because
they can't die and they don't have they
don't fear death and so they want to get
rid of stacks and just take humanity
back to where was season 1 a really cool
dense sci-fi really super dark messed up
violent bloody I really really liked it
season 2 focuses on a love story that
doesn't feel earned because of the way
that it's portrayed in the first season
and then it comes that you come back to
it in season 2 and you revisit these
characters and you're like I just don't
care there's some really cool stuff that
they're doing with a war there's all
this
they mentioned at the end of season 1
there's like another race that lived on
these planets thousands and hundreds
thousands of years ago there's stuff to
do with that there's all this cool tech
there's still all the weird stuff that
people are doing and awful ways of
people are treating each other those the
super Richard called maths the
Methuselah like the people who don't who
don't die and in season one they are
just so like beautiful but often you'll
love to hate them and then in season two
that it's relegated there's only really
one or two who play any major role is
Edgar Allan Poe back he is I enjoyed Poe
is great he's back but he does the exact
same thing as he did in season one like
that and there were some really
frustrating bits and I was texting mike
rizzo entertainment editor of run games
for universe and it was just like a
bunch of question marks like how have
they done this there was a line in that
show in season 2 where it says we don't
have any weapons
we are the weapons there's there's
mobile lines that all worse I've got a
list all my notes are bad light we've
got to change it to the altar one of
these days like no it was like season 1
was based on the book altered carbon
yeah is season 2 based on like another
so in the book series or were they just
like it was good let's just try to do
another one this three books and also
carbon season 2 is based on there are
characters from seas from the second
book and then it's mostly the storyline
from the third book but the main problem
not problem because you understand why
they had to do it when they were making
the changes of season one is the
character of calc calc rest Falconer who
is the leader of these these
revolutionaries who don't believe in
immortality they make her the love
interest Takeshi Kovach who's Joel
Kinnaman slash castle Takeshi no and
like just the way that relationship
changes like cuz I've read the book and
I did for me to particularly enjoy the
book I thought I got some great women's
breast globes it's not this globe just
like luscious glorious or something was
it written 2000 early two-thousands even
like Richard came all these are wrong
and any I don't know like Neuromancer
which was written was that written I
don't know a while ago but I feel like
male writers have some interesting ways
to describe a female's body my dad wrote
porno sometime anyway so season 2 it's
not good I don't like I I love that
world so much because I think the world
is the most interesting part and the
main detraction from season two is that
they just don't focus on it at all and
they make it about this relationship and
they add another secondary female
character
whose badass I just want to see more of
who baby why she looks like the default
cyberpunk Arctic she's got these cool
coils oh yeah trap I loved her character
but played misty night in the cage yeah
from what I remember of season 1 which
to Fred remember a lot but I did like
the setting I really like the themes
like the characters didn't really I
didn't find that interesting the plots I
didn't find super interesting but the
world itself I really liked like it's
it's but I just love cyberpunk worlds
too that's why I'm excited for cyberpunk
2077 it's why I love Blade Runner 2049
and Blade Runner but yeah for some
reason just didn't grab me that is
what's missing from this it's like they
someone went to Netflix was like cut the
world building stuff just [ __ ] make
you action-packed well the main there's
the showrunner from season one's gone
you know late sakali greatest was
showrunner in season 1 row bunch of the
episodes has an executive producer
credit for season 2 but she's the one
who worked for years to get it made her
first place but now I think this room is
that she's attached to build Republic or
the Knights the Old Republic I forget
which one yeah yeah definitely feels
like a change in there's one line where
someone asks anthemic is character
Takeshi have you heard about the circle
which is like this arena basically and
who requires know about guessing it's
round
I was about to joke that was okay this
is like the lowest common denominator
like Gregg and Jenn we're watching
Aquaman the other day if you won't talk
about lowest common denominator humor I
just want to be in a writers room where
someone's making a superhero movie and
every time they feel the urge to write a
Marvel s quip that's not as well like
I'm not saying this I'm not a Marvel fan
girl I like Marvel I like DC a lot
Batman's my favorite but if you decide
to put in a quip for the sake of doing a
quip that's not actually funny
yes UNIX system that would be a pretty
cool role like just like antique wit
just somebody just says no to things you
know I
like I've thought about that with cuz I
feel like every Call of Duty game I play
there's things in that game where it's
like why would you add this is the stoop
like in the new one you can turn into a
juggernaut and multiplayer and it's
completely unbalanced in its [ __ ]
it's just like someone just needs to be
there to just be like no that's stupid
we can't do that I am offering my
services to be the person I love being
that person yeah
I'm telling people now that's basically
what I do for editing knock down dreams
that's what I mean you actually been
playing dreams I mean I know you
reviewed it oh yeah not for games fought
those confused I read it Freudian I
haven't played it for about a week or
two now just cuz it was my life
yeah a lot of weeks yeah so I played it
when it came out but I was in on last
week so I get stuck but it okay it's $40
last week everyone kept saying was $60
oh yes any correction and I was
screaming well listen I was screaming on
the planes but no I I mean I enjoyed
what I played of it like I really I
played through the story which I thought
was very good it was a little bit basic
I would say like or the the Media
Molecule created story and like had a
really a lot of cool neat ideas like how
you jump between different like genres
essentially like you do point click
adventure than you do
third-person action game and then you're
doing like an over-the-top air over the
it was a twin stick shooter sort of
style game it's like that that was
pretty neat they're all pretty basic
though I would say like obviously didn't
get super nice not a challenge but it
does I think it does a great job of
showing what is possible totally like
the last half an hour it goes a bit
insane yeah and you're just sat there
thinking how how if they like any other
game you're thinking yeah you've had the
time to make that but if you've had time
to actually build stuff in dreams and
then you go to that you're like how do
you do that yeah I know that our
professional game versus that probably
helps I'm not probably could be yeah I
was watching our like Jess and II did
like a horror let's play of Dreams just
horror dreams games and in between
loading screens a little input flash for
a second and that was always
funny cuz it's just like these like dark
like PT recreations or whatever and then
load and you just see the little imps in
there for a second
but yeah I mean all I've done pretty
much of that game was play through the
story and then just dream surf a little
bit found a lot of memes and stuff like
that I think I haven't played any games
that are like really cool so far other
than the fact that you know it's still
impressive that people did this but like
like I don't know one of the first
things I loaded into is just fat Yoshi
with the halo music playing yeah there
and I was like alright I can get on
board with this okay this week I found a
someone's done a Simpsons Hit & Run
remake it's like the first little
opening scene in the game and you can
control each of the family members and
just go around the house in that area a
little bit but a couple of bits that
make it particularly excellent a it's
all Spanish language Simpsons and B
Maggie is the star because not only does
she have a gun but she can ride Santa's
Little Helper and when you do that it
plays The Sopranos fiend yeah played it
because in French at school they play it
like an episode of oh yeah we used to do
that but then I always remember you know
the nerd the Spanish version of the
[Laughter]
official one or just someone made it as
a joke but I was like I really enjoyed
that one of the interesting things I did
find on Dreamz that was a podcast people
someone was like someone's doing dreams
podcasts and there was like episode 30
so they'd already done like a lot
leading up to I was 30 I just said 30
because we're on 30 but they'd already
done a lot leading up to it and then it
was like the day it came out and I'm
scrolling through and it's like a 43
minute podcast don't expect two things I
found I think it was Northumbria
University oh did made basically a
Careers Fair inside dreams and you can
walk around and they'd be links on the
websites to like someone made
Northumbria University I don't know what
it looks like they made a building that
could have looked like it dreams
I think they are known for having games
they are cause Ubisoft is oh yeah well
there used to be the center of the
center of town in Newcastle but now they
are in Athens shield another in T side
my actions come out I know they used to
share a building with one of the biggest
solicitors firms in Newcastle behind the
post office next to Central Station I
know that because I used to have to
deliver post to the solicitors love it
good Newcastle facts but dreams yes I
thought I spoken are you gonna have
dreams but I guess the outsiders the
outsider is episode okay we'll talk
about I was waiting for this light
before it'll be fun you sit on my couch
all the stuff I bought from the USA for
you in a bar goes to bags of Bombay mate
yes because I asked you for like
chocolate but then I asked you for a
kind of hairspray do you think it's the
humidity
yeah yeah very fine hair anyway no fine
as in like in you also live closer to
the beach - right so just get wait head
to these face like the rest of us I am
I when I go I never used to have thin
hair and then I got here and now my hair
has thinned out like I was I notoriously
had thick hair like growing up people
are like why is your hair that was thick
and like is not since I've got hair it's
like thinned out to the point where it's
still kind of having a midlife crisis
about whether I'm going bald like I said
I was like I had alopecia
stress-induced alopecia provide good
look if you wanna if you wanna talk
about like stress about losing your hair
I went to the hairdresser once and she
was like what are you doing about this
and I mean this and she just like turned
me around in the chair and handed me a
mirror massive patches ganas oh my god
that happened not that level but like I
was in the shower once and I like put my
hand through my hair and like just a
massive clumps of it what coming and I
was like what and then I looked down and
it was just like hey I was like oh my
god what is happening and like that's
when I was like and then we went to
Japan and it wouldn't stop raining yeah
and like see your shed so like basically
my hair was falling out and every mirror
I looked and I could see my scalp see
living the garage when you see the when
you run your hand through your hair and
stuff comes out and you're like oh oh
yeah and then when it stops I might
alopecia has stopped
um I don't trust it anymore
like I'll run my hand through my hair
and if I see a hair I'm like yeah was
that what it's like no is that no that's
just me yeah exactly so like it happens
to me all the time like I look down a
sink and see like three or four hairs in
LA is that more or less than usual and
like I want to pay as posted that she
got eczema from stress and it was like
other people were replying about all the
weird things that their bodies do when
they go into stress on I think yeah this
that coupled with like the atmosphere
and the humidity here is not good for
them good good for high quality British
hair la may la weather than the LA war
it makes my hair range is the perfect
anti stress I'm gonna make a character
with loads of good hair
enjoy painting in that game yeah it
there's a real like I told this story on
podcast beyond this week on ign.com but
but there's a real like unique thrill
when something you've created is used by
someone else I've seen eater comes the
cheese story but I made a football a
soccer ball that's really thank you it's
a it's really bad like it's the main
problem with it is there isn't round
because there's like indentations where
I've tried to put in hexagons but it's
been used by six people and they're like
half them as you expect worst soccer
football games yeah and but one was
really see it was just called my
brother's bedroom and someone had turned
it into a light like a lampshade the
creations
tell us about the cheese I painted I
have made a cheese that size so I
thought that was just a little game that
no one would ever play it was on Media
Molecule Street in last week's emojis
and I painted a lovely pink flower that
someone used I had to try all these
things out you can review of Dreams on
gamespot home written by Richard
weakling what did you okay bear 9 also
watch a video review on YouTube the
game's book oh you can watch more now
don't go both good the one thing I will
say about the outsider which has already
been said but I'm just too long it could
probably cut some of that out like at
the beginning of this episode they get
into a car and there's just a I was like
oh no not another car episode please
fortunately it's not all car but there's
a significant amount of this episode
where people are in cars driving
subscribe
I want to that's not good television
like I don't want an episode of someone
in a car I want to show out what's the
name that one of the characters the lady
who's doing the
normal sized detective yeah how do you
give me that's the one I want to shout
her out for doing something small
finally like every time like in any
fiction where someone is trapped in us
in like one of those like stations and
is like I'm gonna try and get out of
this little window I always I'm like why
are you doing that you know exactly how
this is gonna go she did the smart thing
where she used the part of the toilet
and your tank of it to break the window
and then double back and I was like yes
well done they smart I paid off paid off
I was like you did it that's smart so
yeah good work huh
but yeah that that episode was also
incredibly boring I'm like I'm excited
to be in a bit but now that done all
two-carbon Tam and I are moving on to
West world or so we have like two weeks
before Westfield Series 3 comes out so
I'm gonna need to re-watch season 1 to
season two in particular cuz you are for
about three episodes oh you missed kick
see which is the best probably the best
Westworld episode of all basically
didn't see any other maybe I should if
people start raving about season 3 I'll
double back and give season 2 and I'm
against season 2 it's got an absolutely
phenomenal cover of wudang clan' scream
honestly it is so good also the paint
black black gonna say that's the thing I
remember most about that show was all
their covers really good I think the
first one had like paranoid android
music from a film had fake plastic trees
just listen to radio that's always a
good I mean that's typically what I did
yes yeah like oh this is cool then I
just throw on yeah okay computer we
could have a great not just playing see
you listen to Radiohead yeah be down
let's do that I'm in the park
Friday we were gonna play overwatch here
in the office and triangular ash skin
yeah Mardi Gras Mardi Gras we could
switch it to a siege for a little bit as
well I just find the setup I do play ps4
this
that's the whole reason I'm doing a
little bit horribly else you Steve
you've use your allocated plugs
yeah yeah
dreams see put created siege in dreams
[Music]
we should create like we should each
shrine create one overwatch character in
dreams I was in prison so before I
started playing don't act like was your
idea for my my big idea was like before
I found out how hard the sculpting can
be and how long it can take I wanted to
make like for some reason my grand
design was an overwatch based chess set
with characters turn into chess okay so
want to make the Queen sorry no I would
be the rook yeah the console but the
tower yeah that's the rook throws out
armor yeah I play rook but then he has
to be informs our scene is just lots of
little Torbjorn turrets that's good but
that was my dear haven't done it so you
see I'm planning to remake scenes from
demolition mining dreams agents no no
there's some great like I'm starting
with the Museum set piece you should
like rewrite it too though to like and
read or do because I've ready really
change the dialogue to like referred
yourself for some time yeah I mean I
could do that I easily do that I know
this probably someone's probably made
like I'd like to go thank you for a meal
Taco Bell playing what have I been
playing you have been playing dreams see
each apex nothing really new I watched a
few new films on the fly oh oh yeah I
watched Rocket Man I thought it was
really really good
it's the film I wanted Bohemian Rhapsody
to because I didn't really like oh is
that not good I didn't mean crap City I
didn't see it but I saw that one see it
because it go the one the best editing
yeah is it won best editing and in the
season it's like oh wow but I just cuz
Pima Rhapsody you have
watch good music and they do such boring
stuff of it every scene is just like
here's how this song was written the
remaining members of Queen had a very
heavy hands to play in that is why they
use because a lot of is just not what
happened which is like people like Fred
like they act like the band broke up and
like refused to play together for years
but I was watching of my parents know
like they act like live aids the big
reunion after one two or three years my
parents are like we saw in like two
months before that yeah and I think like
they use him getting AIDS as the reason
the band get together to play Live Aid
which isn't how it happened it's just a
bit odd I know that I just didn't really
like ends like the thing I love about
rocket man is that it is basically a
musical when it has a fancy elements I
know you weren't a fan of all those
fancy elements I got really turned into
a rock yeah I where he turns into a
rocket tennessee sections which i don't
mind i know like really drugged up it's
a musical I just felt that one in
particular was that a little on the nose
yeah but first that done though for
human rights thing rather than pretty
much every song is them in a studio
going what if we got the crowd to do
this you've got the yet the kid from
whatchamacallit Jurassic Park just do it
and that's it Clark
yeah but yeah just like sitting in a
corner like they're having an argument
and he's just sitting in the corner and
you just say dude it didn't didn't turn
on the baseline man and I think Brian
may just turn sound guys know what
that's not bad that's not how they wrote
songs is it but yeah I didn't enjoy the
humor obviously I didn't watch it I told
you this when we were talking to the
devs I I have to be in a very particular
place to listen to Queen cuz I'm just
like oh I was oversaturated with Queen
when I was a kid and so I think their
music is incredible respect them a lot I
just have to be in a place I'd if in the
last 20 minutes that film is incredible
Freddie Mercury Legend not talking about
an off he's one of ours in it fresh
Brown
oh he's got Indian descent stole him
from us T yeah Wow whatever watch as
well Rocketman which I really liked
I was ready or not which I thought was
fine I liked ready or not I don't think
I like I wasn't expecting a lot when I
saw it and I enjoyed it but yeah I don't
know if it's one of those movies that
I'd like come back to no it's fine
watch his head speak to you for the
first show I enjoy it I was fun that
twist at the end though
what's Bill Nighy he's having a great
he's in Castlevania I always forget he's
the new season before Netflix because I
was scrolling through like the cast list
I was like what's he doing in there and
I finally watched Isle of Dogs for the
first time I thought was incredible I
remember it was but I was there when
someone like realised I love dogs
is I love dogs and they're like I
literally just because I hadn't seen a
diatribe about how much I would love it
and I just was deliberately not going to
see it because I wanted to hurt her okay
did you see it no I think if one of my
parents said that I'd be like yeah I'm
not gonna see this movie yeah yeah I've
been doing alright we made it through
with only about a dozen tangents I mean
we've been recording for like an hour
that's what we do here
people love the tangents wait do we how
long have you been recording unguents
only if it was my way
Mack there's a max how long I've been
recording about 50 to 54 minutes we got
got the cheese coming back max wants to
get back to granblue he's been playing
it on stuff cheesecake I don't know
first one topics Platinum announced new
game hmm
yeah do you want to talk about this more
I saw the trailer no I Platinum Games
one of those games good friend Joe
scrabbles he does yeah yeah I've just I
don't actually think I properly tried
one is very good yeah she's like the
best she is very much so costume tight
like skin-tight costume made of hair I
don't know any kidding I don't think
I've ever finished the Platinum you I
did Bayonetta one too
hmm what are the Platinum Games yeah
yeah couldn't finish in here I will try
the wonderful one wonderful one or now
yeah
I never played Legend of Korra
transformers yeah that was like their
period or they were making crappy games
in order to make their actual train yeah
I tried that beta is the one to start
with like it's real good
she's amazing it is so oh it's so camp
it knows exactly what it's doing it's
the rocket man of video games yeah but
it's less than the nose but no it's like
um I love a bit in bayonetta where is
that I find her she's a super sexy
character but and even though she has
these shots where it's literally like up
her ass I like I don't know it's just
done in such a great ton and
tongue-in-cheek
anyway yes fantastic character Stephanie
any girl what's the project this is no
one so this is the latest game it's
called project GG currently yeah great
game project great game like Girls
Generation
no this project GG but it's Camellia
project
yeah as Rondo come here pay respects for
him he he's saw the last game he was in
charge of more scalebound which was a
fun game rest in peace is scalebound did
you not play a few people player yeah I
don't think I think I might've actually
played it for like a hot minute mmm like
just control this dragon at Gamescom I
think I watched you do that I can't even
remember it like he couldn't been long
enough to make an impression but this is
his his project leading it's currently
very early in development 15 people are
working on just drop the old paper 15
people working on it
and it's the third chapter in what he's
calling the hero trilogy which I did not
know it was a trilogy at any point the
first being it doesn't even make sense
because the first one is viewtiful Joe a
game that was created while he was at
clover and was under Capcom the second
one is wonderful 101 which is a platinum
game and now there so it's like he's
like retro actively created this like
hero trilogy thing here clearly but like
he they described it as like this is
going to be their Ultraman so people who
don't know Ultraman like he Ultraman is
an incredibly popular character in Japan
the kind of character it's from the
tokusatsu genre which is effectively the
power rangers lineage of stuff and like
giant robots and Godzilla star things
like that but so it's incredibly popular
kids usually watch it and it's so
popular that people usually stay
obsessed with it until they you know
well into their you know later years in
life you go their ultraman's everywhere
and like you've got two stores by man
from Doberman from Toberman but yeah you
go and like there that's what this game
is inspired by they say like beautiful
Joe was Kamen Rider which is another
popular Japanese kind of entertainment
product while a wonderful 101 is kind of
like this squad-based thing which is
effectively Power Rangers also kind of
popular in that toxicity on right this
is ultraman and for the imitative invoke
ultraman is a pretty big deal for people
who know ultraman or people in japan and
the trailer actually makes good on that
so you get like this this kind of like
massive monster coming upon the city and
they do this really clever thing where
they get a really cute dog and it's like
stuck and under some like oh it's Leisha
stuck on a rubble and it's like not able
to get away from this giant monster
closing in on it and looks scared and
it's whimpering and is tugging at the
heartstrings and then you have that
moment where a mysterious figure jumps
in between the monster and the dog and
then you
see its eyes light up and then it just
grows in size and you're like they
absolutely nailed the ultraman vibe
instantly like I was like well well up
for that now and the thing that they're
talking about is like they've always
been a studio about making games feel
good that's what's great about being
here and that's what's great about
vanquishing pretty much any other game
they do other than the licensed games
and because Korra was awful and so it
like ninja tales and transformers repair
rubbish before but they're trying to do
more this time like you they want to go
out with a bang on this trilogy so yeah
it's a very early in development but
interesting and really cool and a lot of
fans of platinum and coming are very
glad to see them going him taking center
stage again and even more excited that
ultraman is the inspiration for it and
might be a while since we see that but
they've got more announcements on the
way and so at sushi nova is the other
person who's the other big name from
platinum and he was part of the
announcement and he said the final game
they're really revealing as part of the
Platinum 4 is gonna be like mind-blowing
well me too
so what are the three that so the first
one is a wonderful 101 remake okay which
has a release date now I believe it's me
I just hadn't said anything
second one is project CG the third and
fourth one are unknown they're
presumably gonna announce the fourth the
third ones relatively soon it could be a
new thing and in their new games right
they're not like the fourth the fourth
they're making the fourth one is
definitely a new IP that's what they
said unless I miss miss remembering it
but I'm pretty sure they said the fourth
one is in uip the third one's kind of
the mystery but it wouldn't be Bayonetta
3 right there these are newer now yeah
Bayonetta 3 as far as we can tell is
separate from that they do have another
game that they're working on which has
got like incredibly forgettable name I
think it's babylons fall
yeah it was quite last year was it's got
that sort of pain Thalia
oh yeah so that I don't think that's
included in the Platinum four but it
could be that that could be the third
game but Google has a good name from
yeah yeah so I mean we start that's do
it let's rename the podcast the Platinum
boy platinum is like the thing I loved
about that studio is like they have so
much self-confidence like the studio's
name is like Platinum Games and then
they have a tag line which is like
platinum never loses its luster and
you're like oh you guys like yourselves
don't ya to bring invites pana and
briefly when you play one of the
minigames it says made by your naughty
friends at yeah team angels but yeah
that's that's just an exciting reveal so
we'll see what becomes of it but I made
an awful joke the other day just hit the
epilogue day I've been I started a
second game shortly after a new game
shortly after came out I have not
finished it yet yeah I wanna I want to
go back I was gonna hold off for the
inevitable like ps5 one but I just went
for it over Jake I stuck in my head now
it's really frustrate any way well you
think about it we can talk about the
coronavirus yeah hmm so be stuck yeah it
is yes sir just for backgrounds more
developers and publishers pulled out of
the upcoming trade shows that are coming
up at PAX cyberpunk devs and pub G devs
drop out due to the virus for GDC think
EA pulled out as well as some other ones
Square of limited that presence of packs
for Final Fantasy 14 I think all those
panels are just gonna stream them
instead mmm this is like
disappointing for a lot of people and I
can imagine why people are frustrated by
it I mean I first hands-on with Last of
Us party yeah but like yeah I feel like
the perspective that a lot because I've
seen I mean like I've seen a lot of
people get upset about this online but
at same time I've seen a lot of people
be very reasonable by I think it's
before anyone who has the impulse to be
like I can't believe this happening try
and remember that this is to prevent a
widespread outbreak of a deadly illness
and like packs as is is a hotbed of
gross yeah like Patrick Hawks is a thing
like that exists people are do people go
there with the expectation that they
will get sick and it's almost a running
meme the sickest I've ever been was
after CES one year that I'm yeah and
like I was just in bed for a week and a
half just got hit with the worst flu
I've ever had it was terrible and that's
because the germs traveling around that
thing like packs is public as well and
like you touching everything shaking
hands like and that's without factoring
in an actual potentially deadly virus so
it's disappointing like square streaming
their stuff that's because I guess as
well like in terms of developers PR
marketing they've spent time putting all
that together GDC it's the same kind of
thing like people spend months putting
talks together yeah I mean San
Francisco's said state of emergency that
yes they saying you picked a great time
the head of the CDC absolutely spicy
comment from the head of the CDC not
trying to like ass wage
ice wage any sort of like fears and be
like we're doing our best to contain and
make sure that we're properly prepared
the quote was like it's not a matter of
if it's a matter of when I was like oh
my god relax but yeah I mean I do I mean
I wonder if it's gonna affect there it's
already affecting what the outer wilds
well god I thought I thought we left
that problem back in 2019 our world's
switch port right I mean with new car
so yeah there was a report that you know
Microsoft is gearing up for delays and
they didn't explicitly mention the Xbox
any Xbox consoles but she was saying
that they were worried because obviously
factories are closing down in China
because it's you know the corner by
virus is right there and so also the
reality is that most of the stuff in the
world is made in China so weird consoles
are gonna get delayed I mean I don't
feel be delayed I - Troy just like very
there's decent chance that it's gonna be
shortages but like delays on and
completely out of the realm of
possibility as well did you see on well
I mean this is talk on Twitter so I take
it with a grain of salt but a lot of
people were tweeting that they're like I
wonder if GDC is just gonna get straight
up cancelled because of all these
developers plan I can't imagine but
ggc's gonna look very weird this year I
feel like they said that there was an
addendum to the GDC website where
they're not allowing like companies like
you can't fly direct from China here I
think they were saying but if you're a
Chinese company who's exhibiting you are
you have to have your North American
representatives present on your behalf
Saab viously I mean a friend of ours is
coming and he was like well I have an
Italian passport am I even gonna get
into the country who like beyond games
like obviously this has become a bit of
a thing in Asia as a whole as well like
the potential impact this could have on
the Olympics is what I am like looking
already canceled so Island meant to play
earlier if it gets to the point where
like they need to cancel the impacts or
significantly which is that could
[ __ ] that country's economy for a bit
like this
they have sunk a lot of money into that
yeah say yeah write down a bit there
yeah just wash your hands don't touch
your face wear masks just be clean be
clean because a factory we can although
I did get a text in the middle of that
that Evan who were going for his actual
birthday he's not saying so he might not
be coming but we Kissel don't she's get
bad you know yeah
we can have it we can have a birthday
party I mean there's a drink every day
is birthday every day
I mean Batman told you that says oh yeah
right well the next story is one that we
can talk about free-to-play siege yes
Wow siege is good if you listen to the
audio version I just pushed my microwave
if your ear was just exploded this no
cuz I hit it here it's fine uh so yeah
I forget who asks about it I think it
was yeah I think it was PC gamer asked
Leroy Jenkins no Aston ass they I've met
him before I his name as well I know I
know how it's spelled but I don't how to
pronounce it anyway in an interview they
asked about free-to-play which i think
is something the community is wondering
for a while now because that game is six
years old seven years old almost or no
yeah six years old about almost six
years old five is this good content
something like that yeah
but they asked and it sounds like it's
something they've been talking about
they don't really know how to figure out
there's certain roadblocks they're
saying like like smurfing for example is
one they were trying to figure out how
you do which yeah that's a problem in
the game now I feel like yeah it's head
in that wakes they only recently added
the battle pass so they've got that
source of income that most of those free
to play games now have yeah what do I
feel like to write like I pay every year
for I pay what is the thirty dollars
every year whatever for like the season
pass or the year pass so I can get the
operators when they come out and then
like the I mean I personally don't buy
many of the elite skins but I have
friends who buy lots of them I will be
getting that Tomb Raider one for Ashley
that they're releasing and a couple of
what yeah they've done a they've done a
tie-in with Tomb Raider see I thought it
was just like they made it inspired by
that was announced today yeah I don't
meet Huber soft has done a little time
in all of their games you're bout to
play as Lara Croft in watchdogs leash
he is British it's got a whole campaign
story campaign is just everyone calling
her Laura calling her Laura
but yeah because ash is my main
character anyway so I'll definitely
build on that but won't be asking to use
double personals so what's the point
yeah
siege is good and I will keep playing
that game even if it's I'm very slowly
learning how to play and it usually
involves Simon being like pick this
character and do this I'm just like pit
rook put the armor down and then let me
go graduate a thinker now for their just
giving up I've got something like good
kills in that game and like game-winning
moments so I understand like it
scratches a counterstrike edge for me no
yeah no game gives me that sense of like
you're a hero even okay which doesn't
like rarely is it you've won the game
single-handedly yes like 1v5 comebacks
when it's like your team is like you're
done and then you just pull it off
miraculously all the watch is like that
sense of elation that you get from
achieving it whereas like seeds you get
their hot Palpatine's first and then you
like I've done this yeah I never watch
so I was playing with Sam yesterday the
mighty car event the experimental mode
they have they've changed so it's two
minutes sorry it's now three DPS one
tank to heels yeah and oh my god it's so
much fun it's so much quicker it's so
much faster have you seen the Zarya buff
yes yeah like I put that siege clip onto
a like last week right with like I got
three kills and I've lost eight seconds
and then you can actually point it out
yeah actually hear me just throw my
control I think I cut it off cuz after
that I just shout like that's why I
can't remember I think I fell yeah yeah
I think I just showed I [ __ ] cleaned
them out
I don't swear on Twitter cuz my dad
follows me and I've never sworn in front
of my parents really big clean I hope he
doesn't I mean my dad doesn't sin to
this I'm gonna I'm gonna go through your
followers and find him and make my dad
follows me on Twitter but he his
username is a weird mix of his name and
a bunch of random numbers but he's also
set that for his display name so I can't
search for him so I know he's there
I just don't know under what Nick James
is watching me but yeah overwatch is
also good it's the said the latest
update if they added that McCree buff
yet so I haven't played it like three
weeks is that not that yeah I think it
is I don't know I don't play mcruiz that
old was very good I don't like the diva
now doesn't take any penalty to movement
when she fires her guns which is
ridiculous
anyway yes game I love how we do those
games very good the siege section into a
voyage you hate to see it yeah
absolutely hate seeing should we move on
to listener questions fine
Lucy since you're so excited move on
elicitor questions you don't read the
first one whose home is this look fun oh
wow this is the David Jaffe question
okay hmm
hello this is from Eric from Lehigh
Valley pas that Philadelphia sounds
better Irish uh no no I've been
listening since the first podcast
after hearing guys on the giant bomb
cast and it's something I greatly look
forward to hearing each week normally I
never feel the need to email this
episode however is an exception talked
about last week
more specifically the reading out of
david jaffe thoughts on dreams it gave
me some thoughts of my own all of which
are made of disappointment and actual
anger Wow this man who is what a pillar
of game design iconic legendary iconic
and legendary game designer David Jaffe
says something unbearably out of touch
and misses the point on such a
fundamental basis it makes you wonder
first time when was his last game what
was it maybe it shouldn't you count to
death you hate to see it either
ease of access to technology that is in
turn more intuitive than before has made
lines of game
slash design
slash art all the more blurred point
nests and edging towards irrelevance how
many games do we now have about game
design
how many indie games are developed in
non-traditional game making platforms
not to mention the plethora plethora
plethora of plethora dammit it's a
dinosaur that is out there that is
produced by historically non-traditional
means Soundwave who is a producer for
Ken like kendrick lamar's former no
Soundwave no no D never got ready play
with the song he made in MTV Music
Generator for the PlayStation what if he
been told he couldn't do that [ __ ] that
I guarantee you there are countless upon
countless similar stories not to mention
the mod scene you all mentioned leading
to at least a traditional sense of
legitimacy I understand
it is how he feels and he's entitled to
that I'm also entitled to feel that
using what platform he has to shut down
a means of creation for people possibly
for the first time is [ __ ] up and
wrong how disconnected and aloof he must
be to attempt to negate inspiration and
passion of those who are inspired and
emotionally involved with tools they
used to create how impactful that is is
beyond measure sorry this is a bit over
amplified but it is entirely from the
heart love the show Eric from Lehigh
Valley so for some background right
David Jaffe posted I think the Twitter
isn't hungry yeah he was basically
saying that like people aren't gonna
want this cuz people don't want to make
games they want to play games people
make games yeah I mean short sighted
very it's incredibly short yeah old man
yells that cloud it's not like I before
we say anything about this this doesn't
anything that I say anyway doesn't come
from a place of like disliking david
jaffe
or like disrespecting david jaffe he's
clearly a very talented person he made
it will had a heavy hand in creating
some of my favorite games of all time
with the God of War series twisted metal
as well but this is fully like it just
reads and sounds like someone who's
trying to limit the potential of other
people like and and like diminish any
opportunities that they had like cheese
I will
yeah what baffles me too is like I feel
like every medium has kind of gone
through this recently
where it's like you know films used to
be super hard to make and then the bar
got lower and lower and then something
like YouTube or people could just make
stuff in their free time with easy tools
and sure it wasn't like professional
quality but that stuff still took off
it's happened with music it's happened
with movies it's happened with like
everything it's like but for some reason
he's like nah this can't happen with
games people aren't gonna want to make
games they just want to play games yeah
which I don't know like and I and I kind
of get it in a sense cuz it's like as
cool as that making mechanic is and how
simple as it seems it is I'm personally
not gonna do that I'm not interested in
that but I still see the value in that
like I am like it's super exciting
scrolling through the dreams dreams
scape or whatever and seeing all these
creations that people have made and it
is like even Mario maker which is a
little more rigid or it's a lot more
rigid than dreams but like still a lot
of people were saying the same thing
right it's like well I'd want to play a
Nintendo Mario level not like the mean
level someone created sorry but like
even through that you get so many
creative interesting ideas and then it's
not to mention that or like a lot of
people start careers off that - right
you're like oh yeah if I was a kid and
dreams came out even if I had more time
like that would probably be a very
different story then I probably very end
of that game there's actually on it like
I visited Media Molecule
a couple of months back and there's
actual like stories that they told me of
like someone made a really impressive
gaming dreams it's the first game that
ever even tried making and they got in
contact with them and they were like no
yes I think they weren't making anything
anymore they were like oh did you why
like were you in joy and dreams no like
yeah I enjoyed it so much I've decided
just to take up unity in becoming again
so you can get that bridge into it I
mean it's like how many people are out
there who might have an incredible
aptitude aptitude for making games like
an innate skill so they just design yeah
they can't access the tools that they
need like yeah exactly what you're
saying like not just making games like
how many people are there out there that
are incredible and making music or
incredibly I'm making sculpting or
drawing or making
shitty footballs or cheese or whatever
it may be
like in such a sweeping way just push
aside so many different people like it
could be like I just want to spend my
time honing in on making this one object
and that could lead or like it's got a
comprehensive and like a robust music
making kit someone might be like alright
I can't make a game but I can make this
sound that someone else will enjoy
podcast and to like fully just like in
effectively through his comments snatch
that away from people and be like you
can't create unless you fold yourself
into an existing system it's what like
he's created triple a blockbuster games
he more than anyone should be aware of
the incredible demands stress the uphill
struggle is to get into a position where
you have the ability and also they say
to make something that you truly want to
make and have it get out there like the
hurdles that you have to overcome to
reach that stage are incredible so like
when something comes along like this
that breaks down those barriers and like
it's available to everyone for a which
you know fall intensive personal
purposes for what it is is nominal you
should be celebrating that instead of
pushing that aside and like if he's
trying to say like people who want to
make a genuine things you won't go and
make a real game yeah maybe but like
some people just want to express himself
like we saw that video of someone who
had recreated ghosts of Tsushima in a
trailer in the only read the only way we
realized it was in dreams is because
there was a logo in the corner that said
this is creating dreams otherwise it
just look like two different like videos
of ghosts of Tsushima from two different
stages of development like both were
really impressive like maybe that person
doesn't want to create a game maybe they
just want to recreate the trailer from
ghost of Tsushima and for you to try and
strip them all that kind of satisfaction
and the the kind of like the human
enjoyment of creating and and like
channeling creativity into something
just because you want them to function
inside of a system that you've been
through or you've diminishing the
ability of that person to do that thing
because you're standing in front of a
and you think that everyone should walk
free into the same area that you've been
it's ridiculous it's fully like old man
yells our cloud like grow up it's just
we grow on the mental level lot I just
don't care what other people do you want
you made your gutter ball game you've
had your success step aside and let
other people do what they want make
you're drawn to death drew where is cord
you had that as well
whatever just stop get in other people's
way it kind of reminds me of like the I
don't know when was it I mean I mean I
guess before like maybe the early 2000s
when TV really took off and they start
making like cinema caliber sort of TV
shows before that there was like that I
don't know that like unspoken sort of
like oh TV huh like movies and then
there's you were a TV actor yeah you're
both yeah and like yeah exactly then
like Netflix style of thing and like
YouTube like you mentioned before like I
get more entertainment out of YouTube
videos and consistently than most like
movies and TV shows I guess immediately
available great drawn to deafen dreams
yeah maybe someone will make that game
and make it better and then send it to
David Jaffe and be like to say you
should have done it maybe I'll do that
[ __ ] hole that put all the news on hold
I don't know anything dad on that no I'm
just very excited Russ to get to this
next question because we've been sat on
it because time has been on the podcast
for a few weeks and I've I'm obsessed
with this question I also have like a
story know who's gonna read it Scotty
you can recall you you've got I've heard
you've got a great reading voice
really I'm just saying what's here okay
this is from Henry Bristol and they okay
there we go
after hearing Lucy mentions shopping at
cex and it's somewhat dodgy name for a
high street store at least do you
pronounce it CX well Carrie I thought
I'd write in to share a few tidbits
about my time there I watched a sales
assistant and hardware tester for a few
years and it was easily the wildest
retail experience I've had first of all
the name we were told repeatedly to
enforce the sex pronunciation and our
managers run with it as far as they
could
we had unprotected sex unprotected sex
Wi-Fi networks our company intranet was
called sex life and all the stores got
together every year for a weekend of
camping music and booze at the annual
sex fest he's gonna clip these armies in
this idea right it wasn't all fun and
games though as a store that buys and
sells exclusively secondhand media and
electronics we had some utterly horrible
things to come over the counter
highlights included a blood-stained
original xbox multiple laptops and
phones with homemade porn wallpapers are
you deliberately doing that and a TV
there was somehow filled with urine hey
you gotta go gotta go
I mean yeah the smell when we first
switched her on will haunt me forever
they was taking the piss oh you're in
trouble that leads me to my question
well your best or worst secondhand game
console stories do you have any holy
growls you're hunting for a found have
you ever faced
have you ever fought you snagged a
bargain I'll need to find out it comes
with some unexpected baggage
love the show hope it continues for many
years to come
in Bristol and I took my laptop so worst
thing I ever bought secondhand it was
from a game store in the UK and I want
to play castle lords of Shadow a
two-disc game and they only gave me the
second but some might the story I was
gonna bring up here it's not to do with
see ya see ya no-one's to do with
Granger games Oh Granger games so it's
from my home town if it was founded in
the Granger market up in Newcastle by
sirmione by Hermione that's what I was
thinking about and they were there small
local and then they kind of gradually
filtered down the country and they were
a bunch of Granger games around and one
year this was back when they used to
have the games media awards which is a
whole other kettle of fish that we won't
get into but one year Granger games are
the main sponsor and I wasn't there at
this particular award ceremony I just
saw the reactions on to where in the and
the write-ups the next day but
apparently people from Grange is first
of all there were women in tiny orange
bikinis because that that company's
logos like lurid orange and green and
there were women in these tiny orange
bikinis there were little people holding
silver platters of condoms with Grainger
games branding there was big orange
humvee was I wasn't there I've seen the
pictures I was very like I was invited
and I was like no I'm gonna pass him
this I can't be asked how quickly can
you set your company on fire well funny
you should say that it was speaking we
were talked about the in-between is
earlier the guy Greg Davies was the
compare for the awards that evening and
the people from Grange Games were
allegedly just raucous
just screaming at him when he was
hosting and people going up to accept
Awards and they were like booing them
offstage and yelling at them and yeah so
even pronounce sex screens your market
actually Grange games when I'm not
saying it's related but they weren't out
of business I think yes I applied for a
job there about two months before that
awards ceremony and I know I never heard
back
but you used to work a retail oh yeah I
worked a game which is the equivalent of
game I guess it's the women of games
stop yeah like I was even against a game
station was the better of the bunch but
then game purchase game station and they
both became like equally [ __ ] but I work
yeah then they close down game station
because game station had a way better
trading policy so they were like get rid
of that noise arts I got kind of
discounts as well because a guy who
worked there used to work at the sweet
shop near my house when I worked at
games when I worked at game I did
something insane nonsense that was
probably legally dubious but like I gave
away free stuff whenever like trade-ins
would come in and I'd be like you know
to give you a full price let's not worry
about that because I was like I remember
being done dirty by this company so I'm
not gonna I'm gonna do everything I can
but I would process a lot of like traded
in secondhand stuff and whoo boy the
stuff that I saw in my time I think like
I think the most consistent one I always
found like it was alarmingly frequent
was used condoms in PSP cases
specifically PSP I think it was the
height of it was like I don't know like
I honestly like it was always like so
you do this thing where you get the case
you open the case you pull out the
manual and the UMD and then you just put
the UMD into the manual and then like
rubberband it but like occasionally
you'd pull out the manual and feel like
something's in there and like the first
time I was like what's this all about
and I opened like carefully opened it
and it was slightly stuck and then like
pulled it and it like came apart and
there it was
do it as well no I'm not no not you you
the person oh yeah accidentally I'll
tell you what the happened I found it in
a need for speed case twice someone was
getting real dirty with before playing
me for speed on piece it paper ESP I
think it was payback I think he was just
crank it off without need for speed yes
that one and there was like a cup FIFA
was always the one that like of course
it is like all the wrong ends in it is
kind of people who play Need for Speed
and FIFA but like that was that was like
it happened a lot and it was disgusting
and it was always it wasn't just an
empty condom
he had future generations of someone's
future generations of wrong and wrong
ends just in there occasionally you'd
like feel the squeak then there was a
period where people used to put so there
was a period where people got real real
like
malicious River where they'd hide razor
blades in in Jesus in in like trade and
stuff
wait so Han had you given them the money
at this point cuz surely you get the
game and then you open it and make sure
everything's alright a minute I I like
so I would usually find them when I was
processing it out back so once it like
they'd trade it all in like and like
people like the the staff at these
places were are treated like crap yeah
like they have so much on them like they
they constantly got people who sit on
their ass all day managers like shouting
down the neck about hitting trading you
know kind of milestones and that kind of
business they just open it look at the
disk good move on and like just chuck it
in a basket and then that gets taken and
then someone processes it
I'm sure standards are better now maybe
so like no one was checking it back then
they'd look for scratches is anything
obviously broken otherwise is the case
like does it open is there a game and a
manual but like seven point razor blades
became the thing so that when you all
send it or like you pulled up like
sometimes it'll be underneath the disc
thing so like when you go to pick it up
it would cut you so it was mmm it was
like the I multiple times cut my finger
on a razor blade opening doing on
pre-owned stuff that's not a baby and
like thankfully never like it wasn't
infected or anything ever I'll sit there
I'll go play in it I actually hit my
hand on a wall so like that was a thing
multiple times you'd get like you know
they'd have special dishes that came in
boxes like cardboard boxes that are
thicker you find needles in there
sometimes like multiple times I have
opened a DA's case or a 3ds case and
just found a bag of weed and that's a
bonus
but like yukia can't keep that one like
I was like nah you can't be there in
that you can't be the enzyme the other
thing that people used to do was another
razor blade thing they'd come in people
were because it was out Westfield's and
it was the money so that first one so I
worked in that game that's the one that
gave me the Castlevania thing I probably
told you that but like people used to
come in there people used to come in
there and like they'll do the razor
blade thing but they'd glue half of it
superglue or half of it to the ground so
that some staff member would go us
freakin razor blade on the floor go to
pick it up get halfway across and then
obviously the attention would snap it
back into place I got cut by that only
one star because once you once this you
got you get got by it you're done and
like throughout all of this numerous
injuries never once like a manager come
along and be like are you okay to need
some time off like we should probably
get that checked it was just like pop
lost money I go back to work amazing I
don't really think the question by the
way is do you have any game consoles
that you want yeah I'm not that I don't
really collect games the one thing that
I love that i have the one collectible
is the I think it talked about before
the murder of crows Vega from BioShock
Infinite
I have always wanted that um diva statue
they do that's like yeah we I'm
dangerously close to yeah you almost got
it I was like I had a moment was like
you know no matter you're like I'm
moving to justify that much money that
is to consoles where's that G yeah that
is true and the one that I really like
like this is not a Holy Grail but I've
got the Mass Effect special editions
just for sentimental value but like this
is well it there's an assassin's creed I
think it's a Brotherhood where you like
it comes in a really weird box where you
have to open it
like it's like segmented at the top and
you open it and then when you do that it
kind of like raises the game out on a
little like pedestal almost I was like
oh I love this I keep this that what are
the games in there instead I think it
was spinning Cell Conviction
so anyone who is anyone who wants play
Assassin's Creed I think it was
Brotherhood would get a better staff
game I've only got like two games I've
got on my desk there's like collectibles
ones
persona 4 from when I went to Japan so
it's the Japanese women NBA 2k9 team
because I went to an event we could put
your own face on the box high-priced
collectible that trade that in scope but
it's my face on it
can you put yourself in NBA 2k 19 like
you can build you know you've not been
hit by the NBA cover curse though your
basketball career still they never
started hopping oh we say one more I
mean it sounds like a joke but we are
actually doing a bit maybe lemon
meringue cheesecake is legit I don't
really like lemon cream yeah I read it
oh you wanna read it uh you read it okay
hi everyone I have been listening to
since episode one and listen in every
week okay hey after Dockers question
mark question mark hey off Dockers um I
love the Pokemon stream on community
Fridays Kelly kicked us she did I was
wondering if any of you guys stream on
your days off for fun I love the podcast
it makes my day when I have to deliver
the post in Manchester UK it always
rains here also I saw Lucy with red hair
on a YouTube video is she considering
rocking that look again sometime Thanks
I have actually
now if you think if you search for
GameSpot now and click the GameSpot logo
the one of the first three video is
always the gaming and depression video
now for me so it's like Lucy on the
front with her red hair I'm sad yeah I
got done Dave absolutely jinx days Jesus
Christ jinx days yeah way always rains
we have a fool oh he kind of talked
about it we would stream but we would
all get cancelled I mean it makes it
sound like a horrible Persia streams
every day 11 which is never a good time
for me because I have a lot of meetings
miss my Sam but we are changing to 2
p.m. in the afternoon Pacific time which
is what 10:00 p.m. UK time
what other time zones are available so
if you want to pop on so hopefully that
means I can join her more yeah this is
for like time off outside of work no I
used to you did I used to scream a lot
back in the day just feel like yeah it's
time to just not have to worry about
people looking or hearing me I can you
see cuz I have a lot of respect for
twitch streamers because you have to be
on you know yeah like your best self
sort of thing and sometimes if I've had
a really long week at work I want to go
home and be an absolute gremlin for a
weekend yeah I don't fully horizontal I
want to be eating cheesy snacks in my
Starbucks cheese plate
I want to Starbucks cheese plate if I'm
feeling fancy I don't yeah the few times
I've tried streaming by myself at home
or whatever like before I was even
working here I found it incredibly
difficult to just keep that energy for
the full time especially by yourself and
then I don't know play well as well I
think I think I only streamed like
blood-borne in The Witcher a couple
times and I was like hi this is just
isn't for me because I was just kind of
doing everything trying to get in the
games industry I was like streaming
making videos writing reviews and I was
like you know I think I should just cut
this out and focus on videos and in
writing and stuff my
Delina bingo me you know that's my
demeanor I did it I know I really got
that kind of sue I'm a attitude I did it
for for like Dark Souls was the one I
did a lot but I screamed a bunch back in
the day and honestly like I've been
thinking about it recently just because
like it's it's kind of it's a muscle
like yeah I found it a lot of fun back
in the day to like get obsessed cuz dogs
I was I screamed after I played it a few
times so it was like I didn't have to
think too hard about playing the game as
much as just being fun and entertaining
because I feel like if you play a game
for the first time in you're on the
stream I can go one of two ways one of
which is you and your chat like learning
the game together and experiencing it
for the first time it's great or you're
really bad at it chat slots yelling at
you yes maybe a couple of people in
there who trying to help you up at the
drowned out yeah so that's that's the
other thing about it like you build a
community and like the people that I had
like it wasn't a crazy amount people as
maybe like 60 70 to max 100 people for
like very big moments in Dark Souls but
like everyone was super nice and like I
miss that a lot and you do get a lot of
people like I watch any quarter as I
mentioned again like he's streaming
blood-borne currently he streams apex he
plays overwatch yeah I played all watch
with us and like hey Zeus his toast does
regular blood-borne stuff and generally
the communities there are super nice but
like recently since moving here I've
been like thinking about getting back
into it just cause like I miss being on
streams and playing games and hanging
out with people a little mean we do it
our work as well we do it we do it all
the time weekends but it's just like
sometimes I'm like playing blood-borne
alone or playing something alone and I'm
like we played bubble together once one
time yeah but like when you went on like
single play games at all like it when
I'm just playing on melona alone I'm
like I could just stream this and like
just had people around chatting and that
kind of stuff
I think if I were to stream I definitely
have to like I couldn't just jump
between games I couldn't do like a
multiplayer game like I'd have to pick a
game and like play it from start to
finish I was in on one sitting and then
probably take a break like I do like the
idea of like going on that journey with
people watching you but I could never
just like mmm
like alright it's Tuesday and every
Tuesday I just play some apex with
people like I couldn't I don't think I
could do that
like dreams is an interest in streaming
game yeah feel creating as well my one
of my memorable streaming moments was I
was made away for a Dark Souls boss I
think it was Gwen and my cat rolled up
and I had that Xbox with the touch
screen touch based power button and she
was just like funk and he's went off I
like everyone in the chat just
immediately F's and like laughing at me
I think someone Coffee Jesus CJ if he's
watching like frequently sends me
reminders that I biffed it or my cat
biffed it and like yeah occasionally
I'll get message being like hey maybe
other thing I'm gonna build a PC and
maybe you saw screaming in nice place
each
can't stream of Matt in the chat though
no absolutely not
anyway that's episode 30 of GameSpot
after dark if you want to write in you
can email it you can email us email at
us you can email at us you can email at
us at after dark get a oh my god
you can email us at after dark podcast
at gamespot.com we read every email we
try to do every email on the show but
today obviously we didn't get to one of
them because cheesecake Cheesecake
Factory
you know that's that's how it is
sometimes but where can people follow
you tomorrow I'm on Twitter at tomorrow
h i am on twitter at TV four slash more
hatred Simon not I used to like used to
be SIM card
yeah SIM card was good Cindy card 7 yeah
but that was like the email address I
created when I was like 13 so for always
new cool this my name's can kind of be
like a sim and now it's cardi Simon I
prefer bond to phone devices
I'm at least James games and you can
find me at Jacob deck I think that's it
is there anything else you say baby
subscribe rate us on iTunes
five stars only alright we'll see y'all
next week thanks for watching this room
thank you
[Music]